abone ol
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
var
ya sen cansın arkadaşlar ukalalık olarak
kabul etmeyin ama
yenilenemeyen yenilir bazı girmiş
çileler var yenilik yapmak istiyorlar
Yenile yemiyorlar yeniliyorlar tamam
heraklit demiş Hegel sahip çıkmış
değişmeyen tek şey değişimdir demiş ama
değil Şimdi öyle kolay değil yani yeni
destekler diye başlık atmakla olmuyor
gerçekten
şimdi çok duyduğunuz Ama madem konumuz
temamız yeni refleksler O çok duyduğunuz
duayı tekrarlamanın tam sırası diyor ya
diyor Tanrım Tanrım bana
değiştiremeyeceğim şeyleri için sabır Bu
işle bir Cem şeyler içinde Saadet ikisi
arasındaki farkı anlamak için akıl ver
diye Heh aşağı Akıl vermek haddime
düşmez aklına Erdi ince dilim döndüğünce
süremiz yettiğince size ikisinin
arasındaki farkı Anlatmaya çalışacağım
hakikaten
yenilik yeni refleks o kadar kolay
olmuyor refleksi Zaten bazı doğuştan
onları değiştirmenize imkan yok bazıları
sonradan kazanabiliyor şartlı refleks
ama onları değiştirmek de çok çok çok
çok zor mesela hepimizin başına
gelmiştir böyle Tam uykuya dalacağım
zaman böyle bir fikir adı şöyle bir
hareket yaparız yaparız değil mi Nereden
çıkmışta ilkel atalarımızdan
milyonlarca yıl Diyebiliriz ama en son
300 bin yıl önceki atamız vahşi hayvan
korkusundan dolayı bu aş dallarında
uyuyorlar Tam uykuya dalarken ağaçtan
düşecekken o refleks sayesinde sıçrayıp
uyanıyorlar o refleks onları koruyor
kurtarıyor ne zaman 300 bin yıl önce
300 bin yıl önceki en son atamızı
refleksini Hala biz taşıyoruz devam
ettiriyoruz hangi yeni refleksten
bahsediyoruz Acaba hangi yıl refleks 300
bin lira 300 bin yıldır değiştirmemiş
aramızda saat takan vardır mutlaka
görebilir miyim kaldırabilirler bu saat
taktıkları kolları
hangi kola takıyoruz sol kola niye
yine sol kola takıyoruz
bu
sağa takanlarda var Onlara genelde ki
yoksa bak diyorlar falan
çok dikkat çekmeye çalışıyor Ne yapmaya
çalışıyor ya şimdi ben sol kola
takanlara Soruyorum neden sol kola
takıyoruz Çünkü kurma kolu sağ da sol
kola takınca rahat kuruluyor kurmak ne
demek kurmak ne demek kurma kolu ne
Çünkü arkadaşlar
Eskiden tam kırk yıl önce saatler kur
malıydı Günde en az iki kere kurmazsan
Dururdu Dururdu O yüzden kurmak
zorundayım o yüzden sol kola takmak
zorundayım kırk yıl oldu otomatik saati
geçtik kurma zorunluluğumuz yok hepiniz
sol kola takıyorsunuz
Daha sonra da Sağ kola takanlara
diyorsunuz ki cif ara
o abi kırk yıl olmuş bitmedi bir şey
daha soracağım çok güzel cevap
vermiyorsun şu ne
Ben Kemal
var ama bir şey söyleyeceğim abi
en son yine 40 yıldır camlar otomatik
hangi çevirme kolu ya
yapılması gereken hareket sütümü
Sen niye yapıyorsunuz 40 yıldır
hepinizin arabası otomatik canlı 40
yıldır değiştirebiliyorsunuz bak bitmedi
Dur daha var şimdi kadın giysilerinin
düğmeleri de sol tarafta değil mi mi
Niye
Ne yapıyorsunuz ama gidiyorsun villa bu
ilan eden bensiz orta kağıda Hani
kapıcısının kompleksliği düşeslerin
zamanında Board giysileri elbiseler
giyiyorlar hizmetçileri var hizmetçi
kolaydı bağlasın düğmesinin kolay çözsün
diye ye hizmetçilerin sağına gelecek
şekilde kadın giysileri ne düğme solda
şimdi bazılarının arasında bunların
olabilir hizmetçi şirin var mı var Ama
hiçbiriniz hiçbir Kontes değilsin var mı
aramızda Kontör varsa ben çıkıp gideyim
bir şey iste yok ama hala İlla Hu sol
tarafta olacak abi en son iki Yüzyıl
önce de kaldı kompleksler ya
var ama bak Bakın arkadaşlar Böyle
refleks dediğimiz şey değişim dediğimiz
o kadar kolay olmuyor şu andımızın tema
tam tersinin bilim çok hızlı ilerliyor
Teknoloji çok hızlı ilerliyor insan o
kadar hızlı ilerleyemiyor insandaki
değişim o kadar hızlı olamıyor davranış
kalıpları şöyle bakın 300000 seneden
başladım pazarlık yaptık 200 TL'ye Tıp
seneye geldik davranış kalıpları o kadar
kolay değişmiyor neden düşünce kalıpları
da o kadar kolay değişmiyor düşünce
kalıbı dediğin şudur düşüncede bazen
düşünmeni engeller bakar mısınız
paradoksa düşünce düşünmeyi engelliyor
düşünme kalıbı yüzünden ha ha O zaman
biz
yenilik yapmak istiyorsak fiziksel
engelleri bir kenara bırakıyorum iki
tane engel var yenilik yapmak
isteyenlerin önünde bir tanesi dış
engeller bir tanesi iç engeller ve
şengeller dediğimizde
malum şöyle anlatayım ya da şimdi mi
anlatayım
bu şöyle
iki Türk Dr
bu korunma aşısını buldu ya ya gurur
duyduk ama Türkiye'de değil
bu biri Türk Profesör Nobel aldı ya da
ama Türkiye'deki buluşuyla değil
Neden
neden Türkiye'deki buluşlarıyla
Türkiye'deki çabalarıyla olmuyor yani
geçenlerde bir sorun yok anladık aynı
genleri taşıdığımız insanlar dışarıda
yenilik yapıyor Euro'ya ve resimleri
basılacak ya da ama Türkiye'de niye
olmuyor işte Türkiye'de Elalem ne der
lobisi var biliyorsunuz çok anlattım çok
duyduğunuz çocukluğumuzdan beri
hakikaten Elalem ne der bir yenilik
yapmaya kalktığımızda bir yenilik
yaparsın götürürsün bak El alem dersin
der ki nerede görülmüş
o ulan yenilik
tek bir yerde görünmediği için yenilik
yani ziyade görürsün zaten yenilik olmaz
nerede görülmüştür bunu söylüyorsun
diyor ki ya eski köye yeni adet çıkarma
ağabey işte bak İSKİ köye yeni adet
çıkartmadı ımız için o eski köyler adet
adet eskidi yok oldu gittigi eski köye
yeni adet çıkartmak lazım dışı karta
madık Evet
şimdi Elalem diyoruz coğrafyamız dan
bahsediyoruz yine çok duyduğunuz çok
duyduğunuz içinde tekrarlana tekrarlana
bir düşünce kalıbı haline gelmiş Sizin
düşünmenizi engelleyen bir kalıp daha
var [ __ ] aldığının sözü Coğrafya
kaderdir diyor
çoğrafya kadardır bu
bu fotoğraf Ya arkadaşlar asla kadar
değildir Tamam Evet coğrafya insanı
etkiler değiştirir ama insanda
coğrafyayı ettiler değiştirir coğrafya
insan arasında diyalektik bir çatışma
vardır iyi olan kazanır coğrafya
kadardır diye bu düşünce kalıbının süre
engellemesine lütfen izin vermiyor
coğrafya dedik başka düşünce kalıpları
bir başka coğrafi örnek vereceğim size
çok da tıklıyorsunuz ve inanın yenilik
üzerinde
yeniliğin önünde inovasyonun önünde
Şirin hepinizin Özgür düşüncesini önünde
bir başka coğrafi düşünce kalıbı daha
var Amerika'yı yeniden keşfetmeye gerek
yok Yok yahu
o ulan 1492 yılında
keşfedilen Amerika'yla 2022 yılındaki
Amerika aynı Amerika mı
1492 yılındaki Amerika emperyalizmin
gadrine uğramış bir kıt Aynı bugünkü
Amerika
Emperyalist Amerika yani o yüzden
değil Amerika'yı Amerika'yı da
Türkiye'yi de kendimiz de her gün sabah
öğlen akşam tok karnına değilse bile her
ay bir kere yeniden keşfetmekte yararlar
arkadaşlar diyor Eyvallah eyvallah
şimdi Coğrafyadan devam ediyoruz dış
engeller coğrafya ile insan arasında
diyalektik bir çatışma var dedik ama bu
o kadar kolay mı ne lazım cesaret lazım
Ne cesareti diye sormayacağım şimdi
cevaplarını verin ben kez de kendi
cevabını vereyim al bu başlar Bu
Coğrafyayla diyalektik bir çatışma içine
girmemiz için gereken en büyük cesaret
rezil olmayı göze almaya cesaret
rezil olmayı göze almayı cesareti rezil
olmayı göze alamayan hiç bir yenilik
yapamaz arkadaşlar
hemen kendi sektöründen sinemadan örnek
vereyim bu youtuberların çok sevdiğim
sıçramalı kurgu diye bir şey var bilen
biliyor youtuberlar sanıyor ki kendileri
buldu Hayır 60'lı yıllarda kodat buldu
nasıl buldu ya ilk defa ömürleri film
çekiyor bağlantı planlarını çekmeyi
unutmuş bilmiyor akıl edememiş koklamaya
geldiğinde kurgulu yapıyorlar doğru ve
düzgün bir şekilde Kodak diyor ki
sıçramalı diyor kurtulalım arkadaşlar
diyor ki sen ne diyorsun godart ve rezil
olursun bu dart etme codart Yapma Kodak
Kodak vallahi
tüm bölge yok yapacağım diyor abi
vizyona sokuyor filmi serseri Aşıklar ve
rezil kepaze olmuyor efsane oluyor bir
başka örneği daha var süper gitti Vestel
dinlen türün mucidi Sergio Leone Sergio
O da bir İyi Kötü Çirkin filmi çekerken
saniye çekmiş tam işte detayları çekici
sırada dekor yanmış yapımı da demiş ki
ben bir daha dekor parası veremem Bitti
film Bizim sergi Ödemiş yok demiş ben
çeker bulanması çekersin devamlılık yani
tutmaz dekor yani demiş çekelim bakın o
ana kadar en yakın plan şu omuz plan
Hadi bilemedin baş plan Sergio diyor ki
ben diyor böyle diyor şöyle bir plan
çekelim bütün perdeyi göz doldurur dekor
görülmez ya da diyor şöyle
bu dudak diyor çekerim bütün perdeyi
dudak doldurur yan dekor görünmez diyor
yine diyorlar etme sen diyor rezil
olursun yapma Savcı rezil olsun diyor
sen yok yapacağım yapıyor Yine rezil
kepaze olmuyor efsane oluyor Gerçekten
bunu çok çok örnekleri var arkadaşlar
şimdi bunu söyledim rezil olmayı göz
almamız lazım rezil olmak cesaretini
göstermeniz lazım ama nasıl olacak bu
dediğimiz kadar kolay değil Nasıl sahibi
olacağız bir cesarete bir Bu benim
dediklerimden dolayı aklınıza gelecek
iki çok değerli Murathan mungan'ın i
sözü aklına gelecek diyor ya Murat'a
mangal bu ülkede her şey olabilirsiniz
ama rezil olamazsınız ya Evet oğlum
şimdi bitmiş Dünya ile çatışmadan
bahsediyorum da bir çatışmadan Yine
sosyal medyada tekrarlana tekrarlana ki
refleks Aslında budur biliyorsunuz
refleks budur ya Ya doğuştan gelir ya da
şartlı reflekstir o kadar tekrar varsın
ki beyin devreden çıkan O yüzden
kıramıyor görevini omuriliğe devreder
yani refleks dediğimiz şey de aslında
birini devreden çıkartıyorsunuz tekrarla
ya tekrarlıyor İşte bu deminden beri
saydığımız örneklerde yumurta Hangi
yumurta çatlak yumurta o kadar çok
karşında geldi ki söyleyin
hatırlayacaksınız çatlak yumurta var İki
bağışında var basma yok yandaki yazar
hep aynı yiyor ki
değişim diyor içerden olursa yaşam
başlar değişim dışarıdan olur yumurta
dışarıdan kırılırsa yaşam son bulur O
yüzden diyor büyük değişimler işten
başlar Bence bu bu hem doğru hem çok
yanlış
arkadaşlar Önemli olan yumurtanın işten
yarıştan kırılması değil önemli olan
zamanla Mother yumurtanın doğru zamanda
kırılması lazım yani civciv artık
çıkacak olgunluğa erişti ise sende
kırsan Yaşar var mı aramıza girdi
yetiştiren şu biraz gayet biliyorsun
Biliyorsun Biliyorsun zamanı geldiyse
Dışarıdan da kırsan O Hayat başlar bazen
o civciv yanıp erken kırar Erken doğum
gibi onu yaşama şansı zayıflar
hasretten arkadaşlar iç dış bir tarafa
da tamamlama çok önemli doğru zamanda
tavuğu kırmak doğru zamanda düşünce
kalıbını kırmak doğru zamanda yenilik
yapmak lazım hani yine atalım dediği
gibi her şeyin bir yeri zamanı var
dedikleri zaman kısmını bu doğru Her
şeyin bir zamanı var Peki bir şey
soracağım Lütfen aynı anda cevap verin
Su kaç derecede kaynar
yüz değil mi
Her zaman her yerde mi
bu Normal şartlar altında yarış atları
bağlı Normal şarkı bir atmosfer basınç
altında Yani hep beraber 120 üretildi
bir düşünce kalıbı üretildi o kalıp
düşüncelerini sınırladı beyniniz esir
aldı yüz diyorsunuz
h11 her yerde değil dağın başında
bardağına göre değişir 92 derecede 95
derecede kayabilir yani zaman önemli
olduğu kadar hinlik yapmak için yerde
önemli arkadaşlar Evet şimdi her şeyin
zamanı var dedik Şimdi buraya kadar
şöyle bir özet geçeyim mi dedim işte
yenilik yapmak için bu şengeller iş
Engeller Var Bu engelleri aşmak için
cesaret lazım rezil olma cesareti lazım
ve o kalıpları yıkmak için de doğru
zamanda doğru yerde Harekete Geçmek
Lazım bunu dedik şimdi ya bu kadar
yatıyor mu Son bir şey söyleyeceğim Bu
bu labirent bulmacaları hatırlayanlar
var mı işte tavşan kardeş havuca nasıl
gidecek
Bu tavşan kardeşinin üç tane yol var
havuç var tavşan kardeşi havucu ulaşması
için gereken doğru yolu gösterir misin
diye çocukluğumuzda vardı
bulmacaları üç saniye de çözüyorum bütün
arkadaşlarımdan hızlı Neden
Neden Çünkü tersten bakıyordum tersten
bakıyordum Çünkü Evet tavşan
kardeşimden tavşan kardeşten havuza
giden 3 yol var ama havuçtan O da
kardeşimiz aslında niye olmuyorsa ya o
da canlı tek suç algılayamaması mı Evet
havuç Kardeşten de tavşana giden tek bir
yol var olarak abim bazen işte tersten
bakmak bakış açısı değiştirmek yerine
ulaşmakta doğru yolu bile veriyor
Arkadaşlar şimdi bu kadar zamanda bu
kadar özetleyebilirim en son bir şey
söylemek istiyorum aramızdaki
yenilikçiler E tabii ki Gazi'den ilham
alarak Son bir söz var mı aramızda
yenilikçi Yok yok bu
O ne oldu Onun için geldik Hala mı yok
ama o kadar şeyi anlattı
olacak peki şimdi aranızda bu konuşmadan
sonra yenilik çıkarsa
Arkadaşlar şimdi sen yeni bir şey
yaparsın Seni yok sayarlar
Sonra sen ısrar edersin sana gülüp
seninle dalga geçerler sen ısrar eder
sana itiraf ederler sonra sen ısrar
edersin sana itiraz edenler sonra
seni başka yok saymaya kalkanlar seni
yok etmeye çalışırlar ölümüne sen ısrar
edersin sonra sonra sen tadınız
[Alkış]